Marvel fans across the globe are
celebrating that spider-man won't be
making an abrupt exit from the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and Tom Holland is
right there with them the star of
spider-man far from home joined much of
Twitter and reacting the pure elation to
the news that Sony Pictures and Disney
the parent company of Marvel Studios
have reached an agreement to keep the
wall crawler in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe for one more spider-man solo
movie and another Marvel Studios
production thousands of fans have
endured more than a month of heartbreak
as Spidey's future in the MCU has
languished in limbo in recent weeks the
outlook for the old web heads potential
return has been particularly grim Sony
Pictures chairman and CEO Tony Vince
akira publicly stated that quote the
door is closed on reaping the deal
between the two studios and the recent
news that Marvel Studios head honcho
Kevin Feige would be hopping across the
hall to produce a Star Wars movie left
many fans with the impression that he
only had time to do so because of the
distinct absence of a third spider-man
movie this thankfully turned out not to
be the case of course Spidey fans are
thrilled in the immediate aftermath of
the announcement that Sony and Disney
had agreed to play nice
Twitter absolutely exploded with an
outpouring of jubilation from fans and
media outlets alike
[Music]
cinema blend posted a short clip of
Peter Parker disintegrating in the arms
of Tony Stark near the end of Avengers
infinity war but in Reverse the caption
mr. stark I feel good
who knew young Peter was a James Brown
fan another Twitter user posted fan art
depicting the famous scene from
spider-man homecoming in which Spidey
attempts to keep the Staten Island Ferry
from splitting in half using nothing but
his webs super-strength and sheer
determination in the rendering the two
halves of the ferry are marked with
banners featuring the respective logos
of Sony and Disney and the caption reads
mr. stark I did it for you of course the
name and image of Parker's late mentor
was invoked early and often in all of
the reactions one that really got us was
a still from avengers endgame in which a
dozen different emotions are visible on
Starks face Busey embraces his young
Protege who had just recently returned
from being dusted for five years the
caption we did it mr. stark we did it
sir another similar still of mentor and
mentee embracing put the focus on
Parker's face along with the caption
welcome back kid yes this stuff kind of
writes itself but that doesn't make it
any less poignant some users took a
slightly more subtle approach to
relaying their emotions such as the one
who posted a short clip of fan oohs
finally relaxing after accomplishing his
goal of wiping out half of all life in
the universe at the conclusion of
infinity war for caption read how I feel
knowing that order is restored and
Spidey is back in the MCU others simply
felt like partying such as the one who
asked Spidey Stan's how are we feeling a
series of four images followed thor
ragnarok director Tycho YTD raising a
glass of wine holland looking like his
mind has just been blown Hulk actor Mark
Ruffalo swigging from what appears to be
a gigantic bottle of champagne and
Holland again looking completely
blissed-out in front of a background of
dozens of multi-coloured hearts
meanwhile Holland's far from home
co-star zendaya chipped in with a
low-res gif of spider-man dancing his
webs off but his fans expected the
single greatest reaction
the best news they've heard in a month
came from Holland himself the star
posted a short clip from Martin
Scorsese's the wolf of Wall Street
featuring Leonardo DiCaprio as the
notorious stockbroker Jordan Belfort
to express a stance I'm not leaving I'm
not leaving and even included fans
reaction Holland's post was commented on
by a bevy of celebrities including
Ruffalo who wrote back in a snap had a
feeling we would see you again
Tony Revell ory who portrays Flash
Thompson in the Spidey solo films
commented perfect but perhaps the best
comment of all came from none other than
Dwayne the rock Johnson summed up the
feelings of every spider-man fan on the
planet today with only two words yes we
could not have said it better ourselves
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the MCU are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the belt so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
you